pour notre second débat autour de deux
questions les sondages servent-ils la
démocratie faut-il en revoir les règles
d'usage c'est le thème d'un coloc qui se
déroulait en cette après-midi au Sénat
on va évidemment en débattre avec
d'autres invités d'autres experts mais
d'abord pourquoi les sondages sont-ils
contestés constatent défiance avec un
effet les
la date étant encore dans toutes les
têtes le 21 avril 2002 Jean-Marie Le Pen
se qualifie au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
un séisme politique et un traumatisme
pour les instituts de sondage aucun
n'avait projeté le Front national devant
le candidat de gauche dans les
reportages de l'époque une question
revient en boucle comment les sondeurs
n'ont-ils pas pu prévoir la présence de
Jean-Marie Le Pen au second tour c'est à
cause de la limite de l'outil car le
problème le plus épineux et le phénomène
du vote honteux les lecteurs du FN vote
tout bas et ne le dit à personne d'où
l'obligation de corriger les résultats
de l'enquête l'événement est vécu comme
un échec des sondeurs et les instituts
se lancent dans une quête de fiabilité
depuis les résultats à la présidentielle
diffère très peu des projections pour
les élections locales en revanche les
sondages peuvent faire naître de faux
espoirs comme en 2021 lors des dernières
élections régionales les enquêtes
projetées le RN en tête dans au moins
six régions mais après le dépouillement
du premier tour
ce soir ne prendrons pas de région en
cause cette fois-ci une abstention
record deux électeurs sur 3 ont déserté
les urnes il y a matière a continué à
progresser en matière de d'amélioration
des des sondages encore une fois c'est
aussi lié à la problématique de
l'abstention on sait que malgré les les
progrès qui ont été faits mesurés
correctement l'abstention dans un
sondage c'est pas évident il y a ce
qu'on appelle le biais de désirabilité
sociale le fait que les gens n'osent pas
dire qu'ils sont des abstentionnistes à
la norme du bon citoyen et donc c'est
beaucoup plus difficile dès lors qu'il y
a beaucoup d'abstention de correctement
prévoir ces difficultés à mesurer
l'opinion des Français certains
candidats ont décidé de l'exploiter Éric
Zemmour notamment lors de la dernière
présidentielle au début de la campagne
officielle il est mesuré à plus de 13%
d'intention de vote les semaines qui
suivent la courbe baisse alors le
candidat n’hésite pas à faire la
promotion de sondage qui n'en sont pas
en les présentant comme des enquêtes
d'opinion une manière pour lui de
remobiliser ses militants
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce second débat de l'Aïd
zulfi carpati que bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes directrice de BVA opinion
Eric Carouge bonsoir bienvenue sénateur
socialiste des Landes à une asciative de
ce colloque sur la pertinence et le rôle
des sondages dans notre démocratie
Antoine bristel bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directeur de l'observatoire de
l'opinion de la formation Jean Jaurès et
professeur agrégé de sciences sociales
Mathieu croissanto est resté à mes côtés
évidemment la Fondation Jean Jaurès qui
est partenaire de ce colloque avec
Public Sénat Éric CAO je commence avec
vous pourquoi un tel rendez-vous
qu'est-ce qui vous a semblé important et
peut-être aussi dans la temporalité
c'est bien de le faire maintenant un peu
au calme c'est ça c'est un bon résumé
c'est toujours bien de parler après la
tempête la tempête c'est en général
quand on discute de l'ensemble des
enquêtes d'opinion pendant la phase
électorale aussi bien les présidentielle
voire les législatives et l'idée c'est
de reprendre le sujet au calme en tenant
compte de l'évolution récente des
méthodes de sondage en tenant
on a maintenant des parfois des
primaires donc il y a des enquêtes avant
la campagne donc voilà donc est-ce que
c'est normal ou pas normal c'est normal
au regard de de la tendance du marché en
revanche est-ce qu'on peut
s'interrogeait sur oups j'ai perdu ma
boucle d'oreille on peut s'interroger
sur est-ce que c'est embêtant ou pas
chez BVA on n'est pas partisan d'une
surenchère d'enquête et voilà je pense
que on en reviendra dans pendant
l'émission mais toutes les questions de
la place qu'on donne au sondage
intentions de vote un sondage c'est pour
moi c'est c'est pas un contenu éditorial
à part entière ça doit jamais être un
contenu sur lequel on fait ça une on
titre et voilà ça vient éclairer une
compagnie électorale ça vient raconter
quelque chose de la façon dont la
société évolue dans les opinions se
forment mais voilà la placer au cœur de
la campagne alors c'est aussi le
symptôme d'autre chose du peut-être du
déficit du débat idéologique etc mais
voilà pour résumer donc c'est normal au
regard d'évolution du marché mais
peut-être qu'effectivement on peut
s'interroger sur la volumétrie au regard
de des enjeux démocratiques on posera
évidemment la question de l'usage que
que les médias en font Antoine Brissier
on vous parliez de mais finalement il y
a eu moins de primaires dans cette
campagne présidentielle 2022 qu'en 2017
donc est-ce que les sondages ont un peu
pris la place de certaines de ce
processus de désignation des candidats
non oui c'est sûr que ça joue ça va
avoir évidemment une influence sur la
façon dont les candidats vont être
traités dans les médias dans la façon
dont du coup ils vont être perçus par
l'opinion publique et il va y avoir une
présidentialisation de certaines
personnes qui va être liées justement à
la place qu'ils ont dans les sondages
après on peut voir que ça peut avoir des
effets pervers par exemple Xavier
Bertrand qui était donné comme étant le
candidat le plus à même de mener les
républicains vers la victoire et qui
sait cracher en vol aux primaires de la
droite donc il peut y avoir cet effet là
qui n'est pas non plus dire que si la
personne est dans un premier temps dans
une bonne position dans les sondages
elle va terminer automatiquement en
première position derrière au moment du
vote les sondages façonnent l'opinion
forcément
ericaouche est-ce qu'il peut faire
gagner une élection
je crois pas qu'il peut faire gagner une
élection une élection se situe aussi
dans un dans une campagne électorale et
il n'y a pas que il y a pas que les
sondages il y a la dynamique qui a la
façon dont un ou une candidate arrive à
entraîner derrière elle par ses
propositions par la résonance de ses
propositions avec les attentes de la
population et en cela elle il ou elle
peut être éclairée par les sondages mais
le sondage à lui seul ne suffit pas en
revanche et il peut avoir un effet
négatif ce sondage c'est qu'il peut
éliminer a priori des candidats ou
empêché qu'ils se présente je vous donne
un seul exemple qui est important pour
pouvoir se présenter au présidentiel les
ressources des partis politiques ne
suffisent plus et donc il faut de
l'argent pour avoir cet argent les
différentes banques demandent désormais
que on est un sondage à au-dessus de 7%
dans trois sondages différents donc par
trois instituts
ça veut dire donc le sondage participe
indirectement de la présélection de
certains de certaines candidats de
certains candidats et en même temps j'ai
pas le souvenir d'avoir vu pendant 7
campagnes des candidats empêché parce
qu'ils n'ont pas pu décrocher leur prêt
à cause des sondages même les gens qui
étaient les plus bas
je pense à Fabien Roussel Yannick Jadot
à un moment où on s'est posé la question
par moment cela dit ou la contracter des
prêts mais parce qu'il était il était au
dessus tous ces gens-là ont pu se
présenter alors tout à fait sauf que
j'allais dire que la vous ne faites pas
la campagne dans les mêmes conditions ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que si
vous disposez d'un capital de 8 millions
ou d'un capital de 3 je dis pas que ça
suffit à garder à gagner l'élection
présidentielle je dis simplement que le
même prêt c'est ça
je dis simplement que je dis simplement
qu'on peut pas mobiliser du tout la même
quantité d'argent parce que justement on
n'a pas obtenu de prêt et que on paye
d'une certaine façon de fois l'addition
parce que d'une part on n'accepte pas à
un prêt supérieur et d'autre part le
fait même qu'on y accède pas à des
effets en retour et c'est un cercle
vicieux qui peut s'enclencher j'aurais
qu'on parle évidemment de vous y
intervenir allez-y il a dit les sondages
ou un rôle indirectement les gens c'est
pas de la faute
des candidats que ce soit la question
des prêts bancaires ou c'est la question
que vous posiez initialement sur les
questions du mode de sélection des
candidats le sondage vient compenser un
système qui est défaillant
le fait qu'un parti se tourne vers un
sondage pour voir émerger son candidat
c'est un pour moi c'est un défaut de
ouais ça ça montre qu'il y a un vider de
logique un problème de désignation et un
problème de leadership et un problème
qui le problème du parti et si les
banques pour ce mode de désignation
enfin il faut légiférer envers les
banques pas envers les instituts de
sondages sage-femme défausser mais je
voilà je pense que ouais mais c'est
intéressant ce livre sur la faiblesse
idéologique des parties qui qui donc
c'est quoi le fond de base c'est un
casse misère en quelque sorte quoi c'est
oui mais je pense qu'à l'époque où
Nicolas Sarkozy dirigeait l'UMP et
s'imposait comme le candidat naturel et
pas toutes ces questionnements sur qui
est mieux placé dans les sondages ça ça
montre qu'aujourd'hui il y a un problème
de leadership et de sans doute
effectivement de leader qui soit prêt à
porter des idées incarner un parti
je pense que ça a un impact aussi
différent selon le mode de scrutin le
sondage au moment d'une élection quand
vous êtes sur un système à la
proportionnelle bon vous avez passé ton
jeu là alors que là quand vous êtes dans
un système à deux tours il y a quand
même cet enjeu de savoir est-ce que le
candidat qui est le plus proche de vos
idées est à même de pouvoir accéder au
second et on voyage justement que il y a
à peu près un tiers des Français qui
disent qu'au moment du premier tour de
la présidentielle ils ont pas voté pour
le candidat qui était le plus proche de
leurs idées mais pour celui qui était le
plus à même de se qualifier enfin dans
un sac de valeurs communs mais qui était
pas forcément le le plus proche de leurs
idées ce qui montre bien que c'est ça
c'est le sondage qui va déterminer pour
qui celui qui est le mieux positionné
celui qui est le moins bien positionné
il y a évidemment un effet de ralliement
de dernière minute de votre stratégie
car celui qui est la plus à même de
permettre aux camps d'accéder au second
tour c'est la question du vote utile je
propose que qu'on récupère le la
réaction de Fabien Roussel parmi les
éléments qu'on avait prévu pour pour ce
débat on l'avait prévu un peu plus tard
mais écoutez bien parce que c'est
exactement ce que vous nous décrivez
Fabien Roussel qu'à un moment de sa
campagne bénéficie alors je sais pas
quel terme employé on peut dire d'un
effet de mode en tout cas il y a un
vraiment un intérêt autour de autour de
ça candidature et puis là on est à trois
jours du premier tour on est le 7 avril
écoutez ce que dit le candidat du Parti
communiste
il y en a qui disent qu'il faudrait
aller voter pour celui qui a le plus de
chance d'être au second tour je vous dis
ça parce que vous allez l'entendre et
bien il faut leur répondre
la présidentielle une élection
présidentielle qui détermine la
politique de la France dans les 5 ans
qui viennent c'est pas du billard à deux
bandes c'est pas une question de chance
il faut pas ramener la politique à ça
c'est une question de conviction c'est
une question de projet c'est une
question d'idée de sincérité
d'authenticité malgré son énergie ce
qu'il voit venir arrive évidemment
puisque on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon à 21,7%
des suffrages au premier tour de la
présidentielle Antoine Brussel alors
c'est de la politique fiction absolue
mais dans dans imaginons une élection
sans sondage est-ce que ce phénomène se
produit ou pas c'est impossible à dire
en fait c'est complètement impossible à
dire parce que vu que les sondages
existent et que c'est pas le sondage en
lui-même mais c'est aussi tout le
traitement médiatique du sondage et
toute la façon dont les candidats vont
être traités dans les médias par rapport
à ces sondages là et on voit que
généralement un candidat qui est à 1 2
3% la question à laquelle il est
toujours ramené par les médias
finalement c'est qu'est-ce que vous êtes
plus
utile et ça c'était le cas avec le
candidat du Parti socialiste même avec
la candidat du Parti socialiste le
candidat d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
donc évidemment si les sondages
n'existaient pas s'il y avait pas ce
cette chose là c'est impossible à dire
finalement si la campagne se déroulerait
de la même manière ou non faut rappeler
que les sondages c'est quand même une
photo graphile d'opinion un instant
c'est pas prédictif on répète sur chaque
plateau mais il faut quand même le
redire et moi je veux bien croire que
une campagne sans sondage tout le monde
aurait plus de chance et on aurait vu
des trucs incroyables je n'y crois pas
une seule seconde parce que les sondages
c'est une photo et ensuite il y a des
dynamiques de campagne et ensuite il y a
une attention médiatique la dynamique de
campagne elle se fait quand vous avez
une offre politique qui correspond à une
demande politique si vous faites une
offre politique qui ne correspond aucune
demande exemple Anne Hidalgo mais vous
ne rencontrez aucun écho c'est pas la
photo sondage c'est pas la faute aux
médias elle a démarré plutôt haut dans
les sondages elle a sorti un livre qui
n'a fait aucun flop parce qu'il est
intéressé personne et ensuite dans sa
campagne n'a pas réussi à toucher et
c'est pas elle et son entourage en ça ne
répondait pas à une demande politique
des Français donc ça fait un flop et
vous prenez d'autres candidats qu'on
trouvait un créneau politique on en
reparlera Zemmour Roussel à un moment
Roussel un moment à plus parler à la
gauche Ken Hidalgo ne lui parlait et
alors donc il y a la dynamique de
campagne est-ce qu'il y a du monde dans
les meetings est-ce qu'on en parle
est-ce que les gens parlent des
propositions qui sont avancées par les
candidats ça c'est pas juste sondage
c'est c'est des choses réelles d'une
campagne politique et je suis tiens
l'attention médiatique et elle peut se
porter sur des petits candidats au-delà
des sondages Fabien Roussel a bénéficié
d'une attention identique à un moment
de Monsieur Lassalle voilà genre la
salle j'ai oublié son prénom à bénéficié
lui aussi un moment parce qu'on se
disait que ce que comment ça se fait
qu'il y a que des beaucoup de jeunes qui
vont même si c'est dans des salles de
100 personnes il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes donc il y a eu une concentration
un peu médiatique sur ce que racontait
dans la salle et pourquoi il s'est
retrouvé un écho dans certaines parties
de la population donc oui il y a les
gros candidats mais les petits aussi ont
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont des mauvais
sondages qu'on ne parle jamais d'eux
ça veut dire que
la dynamique de campagne est quand même
plus importante que que la
multiplication des sondages oui ou non
oui parce que s'agissant de la gauche
forcément je serai pas d'accord parce
que moi j'ai vu aussi une année d'algo
combative malgré et en dépit de ce
résultat mais il y avait pas il y avait
mais parce que mais justement et j'en
viens au deuxième point c'est le fait
que il y a derrière aussi des
candidatures individuelles des attentes
or il s'avère que quand vous regardez
justement les différentes enquêtes
d'opinion une attente forte des
électeurs de gauche c'était de pas avoir
une kérielle de candidats mais d'avoir
une ou un candidat et d'une certaine
façon les c'est ce sont cette fois-ci
les enquêtes d'opinion qui ont qui
étaient dit tout à l'heure qui ont réglé
les dissensions par sondage par son âge
interposé et l'unité elle s'est aussi
reconstituée derrière derrière en tout
cas le résultat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce que la question du vote utile la
question de l'accès au deuxième tour et
simplement dans une tripartition de
l'espace politique la possibilité pour
pour la gauche d'être au deuxième tour
manifestement ne s'incarner que dans
cette possibilité et c'est vrai certains
certains électeurs ont jeté un petit peu
ce qui pouvait être leurs réserve pour
faire en sorte de
ouais
carpacites j'y arrive une fois sur deux
bravo
ce phénomène Mélenchon ce vote utile
Mélenchon il apparaît combien de temps
c'est quoi c'est quelques jours c'est
dix jours c'est si on essaye de se
mémoriser ce qui se passe dans dans la
première quinzaine du mois d'avril ouais
je peux même qu'on pourrait l'adapter
avant parce qu'en fait elle le rejoint
une autre question qui est celle de
alors il y a plein de sujets qu'on
abordait d'ailleurs cet après-midi lors
du colloque mais la question va partir
de quoi est-ce qu'on fait des intentions
de vote et quand est-ce que les mesures
deviennent intéressantes mais il y a un
fait qu'on a observé pendant tout au
long de la campagne y compris de la
précampagne qui était la question de la
sûreté de choix et on dit que il y a de
plus en plus difficile de mesurer les
intentions de votre notamment dans la
dernière ligne droite parce que les
électeurs se décident de plus en plus
tard il y a une volatilité croissante
des électorats et cette volatilité on
s'est aperçu très vite dans la campagne
qui a été beaucoup plus forte chez les
électeurs de gauche que chez les
électeurs soient d'Emmanuel Macron soit
de droite et on avait voilà un électorat
de Marine Le Pen qui était assez robuste
et solide depuis le début
tu auras d'Emmanuel Macron a été quand
même assez vite solidifié on avait son
socle de soutien derrière lui en
revanche on a eu un électorat de gauche
que ce soit pour les électeurs qui est
plutôt l'intention de voter pour un
Hidalgo ou Yannick Jadot ou Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on avait un taux de
sûretéchois qui était moins important
qui était très friable autour de 50 % et
ça a duré très longtemps ça a duré
jusqu'à la fin de la campagne on sentait
bien qu'il y avait une porosité entre
ces électorats et que la bascule elle
pouvait se faire à n'importe quel moment
y compris à la fin j'aimerais juste
rejoindre la question que vous avez posé
tout à l'heure sur la question de la
politique fiction une campagne sondage
il reste quoi un sondage la loi de 2016
le définit de manière très précise
juridiquement c'est une enquête
statistique qui repose sur la
représentativité pour supprimer les
sondages très bien admettons il reste
quoi il reste quand même les réseaux
sociaux les fake news les candidats qui
vont dire il reste avec Zemmour qui va
pouvoir dire moi d'après mon outil
machin je suis mieux placée et donc la
question de l'impact et de l'influence
d'autres sources d'informations
moins objectives qu'une enquête
statistique elle se pose donc le petit
sondage il est imparfait mais il est on
va dire celui qui permet le plus
d'objectiver un phénomène et de donner
une information cohérente à un électeur
alors puisqu'on parle justement d'Éric
Zemmour Mathieu est-ce que il a été un
phénomène son agile moi je trouve que ce
serait trop court trop facile on a
beaucoup entendu Kery Zemmour était une
créature songr une créature médiatique
sans que les mêmes qui théorisaient à
l'automne 2020 un complot ourdi au
sommet de l'État alors vous aviez au
choix soit pour faire diversion soit
pour diviser l'extrême droite soit pour
faire diversion et diviser l'extrême
droite et cela même qui nous explique ça
n'ont jamais été fichu de nous expliquer
la déconfiture d'Éric Zemmour dans les
mêmes sondages au printemps
2022 il y a 15 ans les mêmes avaient
supputé les mêmes choses à peu près sur
l'ascension royale vous a donné qui
était une créature sur la GR une bulle
songr une bulle médiatique il se trouve
qu'en fait non l'irruption et la
progression d'Eric Zemmour correspondent
d'abord à une offre politique celle
d'une droite identitaire et
conservatrice Cassius créé un espace
entre un le pénis qui était trop des
diabolisé pour les uns et des
républicains qui étaient trop
démonétisés pour les autres et surfant
sur la critique de la mondialisation et
de ses effets sur la politique
européenne et ses gâchis sur la crise
migratoire aux frontières et la montée
du fait religieux notamment musulmans
sur notre territoire Eric crise Desmo a
su trouver des bouc émissaires et
proposer une approche nationaleiste et
nostalgique qui a su séduire tous ceux
en haut qui pensaient que c'était mieux
avant et ce qui est marrant c'est que
son talent de plume d'anciens
éditorialiste ça verve et ainsi qu'un
talent pour le coup insoupçonné
d'orateur et meeting on se disait
qu'est-ce que ça va donner ça va plutôt
performer mais tout ça ça a fait le
reste qui expliquait sa montée et avec
le recul du temps c'est aussi notre luxe
dans ce débat comment expliquer à la
fois son ascension et puis ça
dégringolade dans les sondages en
quelques mois en six mois de temps mais
c'est avec de phénomènes nouveaux
Zemmour est passé en moins de deux mois
au statut d'alternative alors qu'il
n'avait rien de dévoilé son projet vous
souvenez on l'a même vu qualifier pour
pour le second tour devant Marine Le Pen
avant de se fracasser au printemps sur
l'incohérence de ces réponses et des
solutions qu'il proposait de ce point de
vue c'est ce que j'ai tout à l'heure les
instituts n'en fait que photographier à
la fois cette curiosité cette puisse
être appétit puisse être déception comme
ils l'ont fait pour d'autres vous prenez
Valérie Pécresse elle a suscité aussi
une forme de curiosité quand elle est
désignée une forme d'appétit et puis une
forme de déception sauf que l'effet aura
duré moins longtemps que chez moi et moi
je trouve quand on regarde au final ce
qui s'est passé mais le candidatric
Zemmour et un de ceux qui a été le moins
malestimé à la veille du premier tour
j'ai regardé les sondages qui le
donnaient entre 8 et 9% en 4e position
il a fait 7
qu'elle a depuis que c'est pas
incroyablement en dessous et il est
arrivé en quatrième position donc au
final c'était à peu près de choses son
score alors ça ça nous permet de rentrer
un peu dans le dans le Discours de la
méthode en quelque sorte
Eric et les sondages de l'automne 2021
qui mène qui met jusqu'à Zemmour à 15%
voire plus en fonction des fourchettes
mais est-ce qu'ils ont du sens aussi
loin du premier tour de la de la
présidentielle alors que les autres
candidats sont pas déclarés les
programmes quasi pas connus etc etc la
réponse c'est probablement pas mais on
en a discuté cet après-midi la question
c'est quand est-ce que commence vraiment
la campagne quand est-ce que les gens
sont intéressés quand est-ce que l'offre
est stabilisée parce que c'est
exactement ce qui est exactement ce qui
a été dit la question c'est que Éric
Zemmour a proposé une offre
ultra identitaire que je ne partage bien
entendu pas du tout mais qui peut faire
écho un certain à certaines attentes
dans l'opinion et que seuls cette offre
à cette époque était apparente et on ne
parlait que des thématiques qui étaient
celles proposées j'allais dire à
l'agenda politique d'Éric Zemmour sauf
que
c'est quelques propositions
représentées certes des éléments
importants pour une partie de la
population mais pas pour le reste et
quand d'autres sujets sont arrivés comme
celui du pouvoir d'achat comme celui de
la question sociale voir de la question
environnementale et bien dans ce cas-là
il s'est fait rattraper parce que cette
offre ne le concernait plus mais on voit
bien que encore une fois on parle des
sondages mais les sondages c'est aussi
le reflet de la politique et la
politique s'il n'y a pas d'offre il y a
un problème là il y a eu une offre
clairement identifiée on a beaucoup
parlé de Zemmour et de la même façon que
alors que c'était inattendu l'union de
la gauche après les législatives ou pour
les législatives a fait que le
traitement médiatique s'est focalisé sur
les thèmes de gauche en matière de
redistribution en matière
environnementaux ça prouve que encore
une fois il faut porter des choses sinon
franchement on a que des mesures mais
pas des valeurs je vous pose à l'un et à
l'autre la même question sur le le
moment où on devrait dans un monde idéal
commencer à publier et analyser des
sondages Antoine Briel
c'est compliqué de le dire mais en effet
plus vous êtes loin de la campagne plus
c'est
compliqué de vraiment avoir une
photographie précise de ce qui se passe
déjà pour les raisons que vous évoquez
c'est qu'on se base seulement sur les
personnes qui sont certaines d'aller
voter et plus on est loin de la
présidentielle plus on est sur le
pourcentage de personnes vraiment
certaines de se déplacer et plus et plus
faible et la seconde raison par rapport
à ça c'est que l'offre n'est pas encore
stabilisée les personnes se choisissent
vraiment pour qu'elles vont voter dans
les dernières semaines voire même dans
la dernière semaine les derniers jours
avant le scrutin donc c'est des choses
qui qui sont assez imparfaites mais oui
je pourrais pas répondre précisément à
votre question de fixer une date où on
devrait commencer à arrêter les sondages
mais après c'est peut-être aussi plutôt
une préoccupation médiatique de se dire
oui est-ce que c'est vraiment
raisonnable quand on est en septembre
donc huit mois avant l'élection
présidentielle de commander un sondage
sur notre
prochain chapitre la responsabilité
éditoriale
à partir de quand il faut publier je
peux peut-être plus répondre à la
question de quand est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas publier moi je considère quand on
est trop dans la politique fiction
justement quand on est à 1 an et demi 2
ans du scrutin et qu'on commence à avoir
certains médias et ainsi de suite qui
sont pas de d'hypothèses un peu farfelue
moi je pense que là pour le coup on
desserre pas mal le débat démocratique
et donc se dire qu'on s'inscrit dans la
pré campagne alors quelque part à
l'automne à l'automne qui mais
effectivement sans pouvoir le dater
quand il y a des premières candidatures
qui se dessine quand l'offre commence un
petit peu à s'éclaircir même si voilà
elle s'est éclaircit très tardivement et
si on attend le dépôt des listes
officiel on démarre excessivement tard
donc voilà mais en tout cas se dire
qu'on ne fait rien avant l'été qui
précède le scrutin ça me semble être au
moins une ligne de conduite
l'offre politique à l'époque ne s'est
pas déterminé très très tardivement dès
l'automne dernier on savait qu'il y
avait Jean-Luc Mélenchon on connaissait
le candidat écologistes on savait qu'il
y aura une candidature socialiste on
savait qu'il y aura
[Musique]
de la France donc on veut faire une
mini-france à l'échelle de notre sondage
pour la partie socio-démographique donc
c'est à dire les critères de genre d'âge
de région de catégories
socioprofessionnelles on a des données
c'est l'Insee donc on sait comment notre
échantillon doit être structuré à la
virgule près en revanche il y a aucune
donnée officielle qui disent la France
voilà sa couleur politique à x% de gens
qui sont proches du PS x% de gens donc
la seule manière de redresser notre
échantillon c'est de se référer à
l'élection de référence la plus proche
on demande aux gens qu'avez-vous voté à
cette dernière élection donc en
l'occurrence à présidentielle et puis on
compare ce que les gens ont répondu dans
l'enquête avec la réalité des résultats
qu'on trouve sur le site du ministère à
l'intérieur on dit ah là il y a un écart
typiquement je vais vous donner un
exemple en 2021-2022 les gens il y a une
partie de lectorat de Fillon qui avait
oublié que ça avait voté Fillon donc on
a systématiquement qu'on soit Fillon que
des sous-estimer donc on va remonter le
poids des individus qui ont voté donc
c'est par rapport au vote précédent
qu'on redresse et c'est pas Éric Zemmour
qu'on redresse et après du coup la voilà
les individus nous déclarent ce qu'ils
veulent voter un instant T euh mais on
n'a pas d'enjeux de recréer un vote qui
est nouveau mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que cette période là de l'automne le
mois de septembre octobre 2021 quand
Eric Zemmour est au plus haut dans les
sondages ça sa questionne un certain
nombre de médias et notamment nos
confrères de westfrance ils prennent la
décision à ce moment-là de couvrir la
présidentielle sans publier aucun
sondage on va écouter l'un des
directeurs départementaux du du journal
c'était le 25 octobre dernier chez nous
sur Public Sénat dans la matinale
nous on estime à Ouest-France que ce
n'est plus possible nous refusons de
participer comme le dit François-Xavier
lefran à cette grande manipulation qui
consiste à finalement à fabriquer
l'opinion sans parler des propositions
des candidats le cœur du métier de
journaliste c'est quoi c'est l'info et
le sondage n'apporte pas d'infos il y a
tellement mieux à faire comparer les
programmes des candidats réaliser des
portraits fouillés des candidats aussi
donner la parole comme nous le faisons
jour après jour dans nos 41 éditions aux
habitants de nos territoires allez voir
tous ces jeunes qui ne votent pas
réaliser des reportages des enquêtes de
l'analyse il y a beaucoup à dire
beaucoup à faire croyez-moi
dont on parle c'est les sondeurs les les
médias et les politiques qui sont les
plus accros en quelque sorte
je pense qu'effectivement et à la
question de l'offre et de la demande
alors en termes de en terme de
dépendance je sais pas où est le niveau
le plus élevé c'est clair que pour les
acteurs politiques c'est important parce
que ça conditionne aussi des carrières
sa condition des possibilités mais pour
revenir à ce qui vient d'être dit
le sondage
c'est ce que disait d'aller tout à
l'heure le sondage n'est qu'une
information parmi d'autres et elle ne
doit pas se substituer au reste donc
c'est pas il n'y a pas de vrai
opposition avec ce que dit le
représentant de Ouest-France c'est que
tout ce qu'il a dit qu'il faisait il
faut continuer à le faire et les
sondages viennent donner des
informations les enquêtes d'opinion
viennent donner des informations
complémentaires mais pensez que ces
informations à elle seule suffisent
c'est bien tendance c'est bien entendu
faux et c'est d'ailleurs le problème
quand on se limite à ça quand on
éditorialise un résultat c'est ça le
problème oui mais c'est vrai aussi
Antoine Bruxelles que ses parents le
découvre pas ce soir ça fait des
décennies qu'on voit les programmes un
peu passé au second plan surtout dans
une présidentielle surtout avec le
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours surtout
avec la personnalisation enfin bon voilà
on a brassé ces thèmes depuis de
nombreuses années c'est pas nouveau mais
il faut quand même le rappeler il faut
le rappeler en effet on notamment on
différencie ce qui relève de des enjeux
politiques alors la façon de traiter les
programmes politiques dans les médias et
ce qui relève du jeu politique c'est un
peu le la médiatisation de toutes les
petites phrases entre entre les
candidats la médiatisation notamment des
sondages voilà toute les ralliements de
d'un tel et Intel à un parti est-ce que
l'on remarque c'est que jamais le jeu
médiatique n'est aussi important que
dans une période électorale au moment de
la présidentielle et qu'à côté de ça on
a une augmentation croissante de la part
prise par cette focalisation sur le jeu
médiatique au détriment des enjeux
médiatiques par les médias au moment des
élections alors que c'est le moment où
il faudrait au contraire manger dans les
programmes et donc c'est disons que
c'est une sorte de cercle de cercle
vicieux parce que on va demander aux
candidats de réagir sur le fait qu'il
soit monté dans un sondage qui soit
descendu donc le candidat va être plutôt
aussi amené à parler de ces choses-là
donc ce qui peut avoir aussi un effet
plutôt négatif c'est aussi parfois une
facilité journalistique Mathias
c'est-à-dire que tous les journalistes
tous les médias ne se contentent pas de
la cour de la cour de petits chevaux
moi on va dire je prends ma chapelle
mais j'ai trouvé que pendant cette
campagne on a eu des émissions à des
heures de grande écoute qui duraient
parfois deux heures trois heures sur des
questions de fond on ne demandait pas
juste aux gens pourquoi ils étaient
comme ci comme ça des débats
on a parlé pendant cette campagne de
pouvoir d'achat on a parlé de nucléaire
on a parlé de politique étrangère si on
tourne parlait jamais avant c'est comme
tous les gens qui disent il y a pas eu
de campagne moi je trouve qu'il y a une
suite
à côté on l'a fait ici ensemble mais à
côté de ça il y avait les Rolling alors
on va rappeler ce que c'est c'est un
sondage quotidien c'est ça donc ça ça
une espèce de machine permanente de de
de classement des des candidats le
Rolling très à l'aise pour en parler
parce que nous en pratique pas plutôt
chez Bébé partisan de la parcimonie en
termes de sondage et justement de de
l'ajout d'autres
d'autres approches pour pouvoir étoffer
un petit peu parce qu'encore une fois on
considère que le sondage Mathieu
croissanto l'a rappelé c'est une
photographie un instant TS ce qui est
intéressant c'est la dynamique c'est
vraiment de le film si vous voyez sur la
sur la période et c'est ce que ça nous
dit de d'une campagne électorale de et
des attentes des Français et donc nous
on a justement on parle de la campagne
et de ce que alors Antoine dit la
campagne a surtout traité le jeu
politique plutôt que les enjeux
Mathieu croissanto dit l'inverse mais
des Français ont ressenti quand même une
forme de déception par rapport à la
campagne et nous ça on l'a mesuré alors
pas tant dans nos enquêtes quantitatives
que dans un dispositif qualitatif qu'on
avait mis en place avec avec un signe
tank concurrent de la Fondation Jaurès
donc j'ose pas les citer bon voilà on a
suit une corde de français une centaine
pendant des mois et des mois et on a
dialogué avec eux de manière voilà
c'était un dialogue et ils nous ont dit
que cette campagne après deux ans de
covid il pensait qu'elle m'en allait
parler problème sociaux école éducation
santé ils ont trouvé qu'on en parlait
pas suffisamment et en tout cas il y
avait un peu un bruit médiatique qui a
été très autour justement
agenda imposé par Eric Zemmour pendant
tout l'automne jusqu'au congrès LR qui
est lui aussi a été sur cette thématique
très droitière il y a eu une forme
parfois de déception de la part des
Français et ça les enquêtes d'opinion en
cas ils vont quantique permettent de
l'appréhender c'est ça qui est
intéressant plus que la course des
petits chevaux mais Mathieu c'est vrai
aussi si on essaye de d'être honnête de
balayer un peu devant notre porte que
c'est aussi un objet facile à facile à
commenter dans une bien sûr
j'ai sans doute cédé assez de facilité
de temps en temps c'est vrai que c'est
souvent on est dans les petits fours en
ce sens où on regarde comment ça se
positionne mais après
les journaux téléviseur regardez les 20h
ils avaient chacun leur sondage mais il
donnait pas la course à petits chevaux
tous les jours l'utilisation des Rolling
elle se fait surtout sur les réseaux
sociaux par les gens qui en sont friand
et les premières personnes qui en
souffrent friandes il faut rappeler
c'est quand même le monde politique qui
les commandes et qui se dit où j'en suis
ah ben j'ai pris un demi point c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai dit ça dans une
interview ça a imprimé déjà retenu enfin
mais n'importe quoi les gens la moitié
des gens connaissaient pas la moitié des
candidat donc il faut pas non plus ce
gargariser avec les sondages c'est une
facilité médiatique quand on se fait ça
une sur un sondage moi je trouve que
c'est un outil journalistique quand
c'est en complément d'une enquête d'un
reportage d'un portrait d'une analyse
faut pas non plus jeter le bébé que on
est d'accord c'est pour ça qu'il y a
cette équipe cette subtilité dans ce
débat on essaye toujours de le maintenir
Éric et rouge c'est vrai ce que dit
Mathieu sur le le disais tout à l'heure
sur un peu provocateur en disant qu'il
est plus accro mais il y a quand même on
a on voit des inflexions de de campagne
de sondage de de campagne électorale en
fonction des sondages c'est une évidence
j'essaye pas alors de la même façon que
vous j'essaye pas de me défausser en
disant que bien entendu non mais les
sondages sont les sondages sont
forcément importants parce que ça a pas
un moment T et c'est souvent d'ailleurs
je pense que certains politiques
devraient faire un petit peu de
méthodologie des sciences sociales de
temps à autre à un moment tu es ça sert
pas mais effectivement la question c'est
la question de la de la dynamique et
c'est ça qu'il faut appréhender voir au
jour
au jour le jour sa montée ou ça descente
et penser qu'effectivement tel machin
qu'on aurait pu dire la veille à un
congrès a fait que le demi-point est
acquis c'est complètement fallacieux
c'est plutôt la dynamique qu'il faut
pouvoir appréhender et voir justement si
on est dans la bonne ou la mauvaise
alors est-ce qu'il faut changer de
méthode ou en tout cas en instauré de
nouvelles de nouvelles règles au
sondages et aux médias surtout qu'il est
qu'il est publié écoutez ce que ce qu'on
disait Thomas piquetti alors on est on
est pas dans cette campagne
présidentielle on est dans la précédente
il conseillait à l'époque il était dans
l'équipe de Benoît Hamon on est le 12
avril 2017 on est à moins de deux
semaines du premier tour il y a un vrai
sujet sur le fait qu'on n'oblige pas les
institutions d'âge à révéler leur
soi-disant le secret de fabrication qui
sont des trucs totalement foireux qu'on
les on les oblige pas à publier
uniquement des intervalles de confiance
et non pas des points c'est pour
alimenter le débat faire du buzz de
Kaamelott alors que s'ils avaient leurs
intérêts de confiance à chaque fois
évidemment il serait bien obligé en
faire moins parce que tout le monde se
rendrait compte que toutes ces
discussions sur un tel a pris un point
où charient-elle a perdu deux points
donc absolument aucun sens alors avoir
quelles sont les règles en vigueur je
propose à Audrey betas de nous rejoindre
une nouvelle fois sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Audrey son âge encadré par une
loi qui date à dire oui Thomas rendez
vous quand il s'agit d'une loi du 19
juillet 1977 qui fait encore référence
elle encadre à l'époque les sondages
électoraux diffusés par les organes de
presse nous sommes quand même à une
époque où l'Internet de grand public
n'existe pas encore évidemment depuis
les choses ont bien changé deux chiffres
pour vous donner une idée en 1995 on
compte 157 sondages réalisés dans
l'année aujourd'hui il y en a certaines
périodes jusqu'à 5 par jour et donc en
2011 le Sénat décide d'encadrer tout ça
avec une proposition de loi
transpartisane portée par les sénateurs
socialistes jean-Pierre Sueur et le
républicain Hugues Portelli ils veulent
rendre la publication des sondages plus
transparentes
pas beaucoup de sondages aujourd'hui qui
traite des questions politiques mais qui
sont en dehors du champ de la loi or la
distinction entre les sondages
politiques et les sondages électoraux et
de plus en plus insaisissables puisque
on fait aujourd'hui et son injecteur
quasiment toute l'année et même les
années où il y a pas d'élections le
texte est voté à l'unanimité au Sénat
mais il ne sera jamais inscrit à l'ordre
du jour à l'Assemblée nationale il faut
attendre 2016 pour que cette proposition
de loi soit adoptée sous la forme cette
fois d'un amendement dans un texte plus
large sur les élections tout sondage
doit désormais être accompagné du nom de
l'organisme qu'il a commandé de celui
qui l'a réalisé de celui qui l'a financé
ensuite toutes les questions doivent
être envoyées à la Commission des
sondages qui encadrent cela la marge
d'erreur des résultats publiés ou des
fusées doit être indiquée tout comme les
critères de redressement dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure merci beaucoup
Audrey Adélaïde zulfi carpacitz cette
histoire de de marge d'erreur en quelque
sorte c'est vrai qu'elle est elle est
proposée on peut la lire en général
en microscopique et donc ça passe
totalement inaperçu est-ce que ça c'est
une potentielle amélioration c'est à
dire que plutôt que de donner un chiffre
qui peut être dressé qui peut être une
moyenne etc donner la marge finalement
alors plus qu'une fourchette quoi plus
qu'une potentielle c'est une réelle dans
dans la campagne électorale qu'on vient
de vivre plusieurs instituts dont BVH ou
de le dire on a on a présenté dans nos
rapports d'études ont pu nos graphiques
avec un seul chiffre mais bien en
fourchette et donc c'est vrai que
visuellement vous voyez quand deux
candidats qui sont là à 19% le tradi à
18 vous voyez qu'en fait en mettant des
démarches d'erreur de manière colorée
vous voyez qu'en fait ils sont au coude
à coudre et dans un mouchoir de poche
donc on l'a fait beaucoup de mes
confrères l'ont fait également la
question c'est celle de l'utilisation
qu'un effet par les médias autant sur un
c'est pas un bon titre si on prend quand
même saluer l'effort qui est fait y
compris par des médias enfin médias et
je pense à notre partenaire qui était
une radio c'est pas évident de dire en
radio mais ils ont fait cet effort de
dire systématiquement Marine Le Pen
serait en seconde position avec un score
compris entre ils l'ont rappelé à chaque
fois non c'est sûr quand vous êtes sur
un 51 49 sur un second tour ça fait
moins rêver qu'un voilà on peut moins
affirmer qui est le gagnant mais c'est
vrai que je pense qu'on a tous à gagner
de cet effort et voilà et il y a une
vraie évolution de ce point de vue
depuis depuis la dernière campagne
électorale s'il y a une évolution une
proposition qui vous semble
potentiellement efficace
peut-être pas une proposition
directement sur le sur les sondages
électoraux en eux-mêmes mais parce que
on parle que de ça depuis tout à l'heure
du sondage électoral alors que en
réalité le travail d'un institut de
sondage le c'est pas seulement le pour
une élection le finalement le les
intentions de vote et ce genre de choses
et de d'aussi s'intéresser davantage
plus aux valeurs à toutes les enquêtes
quantitatives qui peuvent être faites
sur ce genre de thématique et qui
permettent davantage d'avoir de billes
finalement pour expliquer ce qui se
passe dans la société que de juste
s'intéresser à la course de petits
chevaux avec de sondages électoral au
moment d'une élection
eric est rouge vous sortez de ce
colloque qui a été organisé au Sénat
qu'est-ce qui peut ça peut aboutir à des
propositions ça peut aboutir à une
réforme éventuelle alors des
propositions sans doute l'idée c'est que
les
techniques ont changé dans le temps voir
si la loi est encore j'allais dire en
phase avec la réalité des pratiques elle
perd un peu plus de transparence on
devrait parler tout à l'heure des de ce
que
plus exactement des renseignements qui
doivent être fournis par dans le cadre
d'un sondage mais certains sont publics
d'autres ne concernent que la Commission
des sondages peut-être aller vers une
plus grande vers une plus grande
transparence il y a des il y a des
choses des choses qu'il faut pas faire
par exemple quand on répond à une
question
mais en fait l'effectif des gens qui
sont sûrs d'aller voter pour un sur
cette question ils sont de 350 sur 1000
et qu'on on se base sur des échantillons
plus petits que celui qui est
l'échantillon premier ça pose des
difficultés il y a des renseignements
qu'on peut donner en plus mais ce qu'il
faut et là il faut vraiment
l'accorder aux différentes entreprises
et instituts de sondage il y a dans le
temps une progression vers la volonté de
donner de plus en plus de renseignements
au-delà des simples chiffres et des
simples et des simples résultats et je
pense qu'il faut conforter cette
tendance parce qu'elle bénéficie au
débat démocratique sur les dates
auxquelles les sondages sont autorisés
moi je me souviens d'une époque où il y
avait pas de sondage dans la dernière
semaine qui qui précède le vote on a on
a entendu
des soutiens d'Eric Zemmour demandés à
ce qu'on revienne à ce à ce système là
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai pas d'avis complètement arrêté sur
le sujet même si je pense que c'est un
peu
indépendants et trouver un sondage qui
vient d'être dit Belgique donc on peut
et c'est assez hypocrite en fait
les partis politiques de commander des
sondages et être les seuls à les
assistants
les instituts doivent faire preuve de
plus de transparence c'est sûr nous les
médias de plus de pédagogie c'est vrai
qu'on doit expliquer aux gens on a
commencé à le faire parce que c'est
qu'une marge d'erreur parce que c'est
les politiques peut-être plus de
modération dans la consommation des
sondages et puis après les gens qui les
reçoivent peut-être de moins
d'instrumentalisation parce que un
sondage vous le vipendez quand il vous
déplaît vous le célébrer vous le poussez
en avant quand il vous plaît et parfois
ce sont les mêmes qui suspectent les
instituts d'être payés par tel ou tel de
faire monter l'opinion faut se souvenir
qu'on est quand même en démocratie que
la chose qui fait le vote c'est quand
même le bulletin c'est pas le sondage
d'ailleurs ça coûte combien ça coûte
combien ça coûte pas très cher et ont
d'ailleurs on l'a dit ça peut être un
problème mais brise ceinturier l'a
rappelé alors il y a les sondages que
vous allez faire pour des candidats mais
les sondages qu'on fait en partenariat
avec des médias
brise disaient que pour le panel
électoral enfin on a du mal à rentrer
dans l'eau frais parce que c'est aussi
on rentre un peu dans la roue de la
cuisine mais c'est quoi c'est parce que
dizaines de milliers la donnée est
beaucoup moins chère qu'elle était
constaté du téléphone ou du ou du face à
face pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur une enquête par internet si
vous voulez de vous demain faire une
enquête par internet et acheter
1500 réponses à des questionnaires ça va
vous coûter juste d'avoir ces terrains
même pas 5000 euros après la question de
l'intelligence qui a derrière de
l'analyse de la méthode et donc ça qu'on
gère très valorisé c'est le temps qu'on
va passer dessus mais c'est pas très
très cher et c'est vrai que vous avez
raison c'est sans doute un problème et
alors autre question qu'est-ce que ça
que représente les sondages politiques
dans dans le chiffre d'affaires c'est
c'est c'est 1% même pas enfin c'est les
sondages politiques par rapport même
enfin il faut dire que les instituts de
sondages ont une économie qui est
organisé surtout autour des études
marketing mais même un département comme
le mien qui a un département qui ne fait
que des études d'opinion ça représente
moins de 5% ramener parce que le gros de
nos études sont des études d'opinion qui
vident à éclairer et décideurs
économiques publics voilà donc c'est pas
grand chose mais un enjeu de Fort de
visibilité et de crédibilité donc on
fait pas n'importe quoi merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat et moi je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h et 22h pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
votre prochain rendez-vous politique
vous le voyez dans la matinale rien de
Mancini reçoit Stanislas Guérini le
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique belle soirée
[Musique]